-Welcome back, guys.
It is time for
"Tonight Show Hashtags."
Here we go.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-♪ Hashtags ♪
♪ Hashtags ♪
-Now, we do this thing every
week where I send out a hashtag
and ask you guys
to respond to that topic.
This week, I sent out
the hashtag "MyWorstCar."
-Oh.
-Asked you guys to
share stories about
the worst car you've ever had.
Within minutes it was a trending
topic, so thank you for playing.
[ Cheers and applause ]
What was your worst car?
-I had so many worst cars.
-I know.
My grandpa had a car that had a
hole that I could see the --
I could see through.
-See the floor? Yeah.
-I could see the street, yeah.
-My friend had that
and we drove over a puddle
and water shot up
like a fire hose.
One car I had,
the brakes went out.
I was going, "Oh, wow.
The brakes are out.
That's weird."
Downshifted it, parked,
and went...
[ Gasping ]
-Yeah, exactly.
My dad had a car -- The most
expensive car we ever had.
It was a beautiful car,
velour interior.
-Ooh! Velour.
-Not too hot in the summer,
not too cold in the winter.
Kind of cozy, yeah.
And he was cleaning out
the engine
or something like that
or something.
-Yeah, with that gunk spray?
-I think it's called
Gunk Spray, yeah.
Also, what is he doing?
He shouldn't do that.
-You just spray it in
the carburetor,
try to get it to start.
-Yeah, but he shouldn't do that.
-What happened?
-He just doesn't know how
to fix cars.
What is he doing?
So, anyways, he did that,
and it lit fire, right?
And so he's like --
He freaked out.
He didn't know what to do,
so he closed the hood
thinking that
would put the fire out.
And then it just kept --
It got bigger.
And then he was trying to
open the hood.
It's one of those latches where
you've got to kind of pull
the button and --
And he's burning his fingers
trying to open the hood.
And then he's like, "I can't."
And then the neighbor's like,
"You need help, Jim?"
And he's like,
"My car's going to blow up."
And they're like, "What?!
Oh, my God!"
So they ran inside,
and then my dad told us
the car is going to blow up.
My mom made us lay on the floor.
She thought the windows
were going to break.
-She's seen the movie, yeah.
-They called
the fire department.
Yeah, he totaled his car.
-Oh!
-That was the last
good car we ever had.
Yeah. Anyways, here you go.
These are going to be worse.
Here we go. My worst car.
This one's from @kyledice23.
He says...
[ Applause ]
Wow! That's rough. That's rough.
-Hold on. Stop.
Made a mistake.
-Hazards,
hazards, hazards, hazards.
-Those are your flashers.
[ Laughter ]
-This one is from
@JakeWilliamsArt.
He says...
-♪ Low ri...♪
-This one is from
@BullsOnParade78.
He says...
Yeah, just don't touch it.
-Don't mess with it.
-It works. Don't mess, dude.
It works, right?
-It works.
-Go. Don't worry about it.
This one's from @pdb435.
He says...
[ British accent ]
Make a right turn!
-"Grr! Turn left!"
-This one is from @NickLewis37.
He says...
-Oh!
-Come back around
for you, buddy!
I'll come back around.
You okay?
-Get the broom!
-Tuck and roll, buddy!
Keep the broom.
[ Laughs ]
This one's from @lmittz6012.
He says...
-Steering wheel?
-This one's from @xo carolyn.
She says...
-Yeah.
-I remember
my friend Dennis once got --
We got in a car accident.
Everyone was fine.
But he was the only one
that had a car,
and so we all jumped in the car.
And he had three people
in his trunk?
-Oh.
-Well, maybe one person.
It was one person in the trunk.
But it was the quarterback for
the high-school football team.
-In the trunk.
-Sure.
-And then like six people
in his car.
-Yeah.
-And he hit a telephone pole.
[ Audience "Oohs" ]
Everyone's fine, except --
You wouldn't believe this.
The telephone pole
cracked, fell,
and the wires pulled the siding
off the side of a house.
So the siding of a human being's
house came down,
and he illegally had
the quarterback in the trunk.
But we didn't -- we didn't tell
the police that that happened.
Everyone was fine.
It was like,
"Yeah, who's got shotgun?"
"I got trunk."
"Okay, cool."
-I'll take siding.
I got siding.
-This last one's from
@MrMadeMedia.
He says...
There you go. He's being honest.
There you have it.
Those are our
"Tonight Show Hashtags."
To check out more of
our favorites,
go to tonightshow.com/hashtags.